Thanks I wonder answer the question
about whether the rich countries are
doing enough to help the poorest
countries first off I believe that even
in this global downturn and deep
recession that we've had in the UK and a
huge problem with our budget deficit we
should protect what we spend on overseas
a than the target we have from not point
seven percent of GDP we should keep that
Britain is a compassionate generous
nation as we're showing in terms of the
giving 280 you should continue with that
but why is it that we haven't done
better in Haiti it's amazing some of
things that are being done the pictures
we see of children being pulled from the
rubble is made us proud of what our
emergency services were able to do that
but I do think the UN and individual
countries as well need to think more
about how we can have a standing ready
to go emergency force so that we make
sure that in the vital golden first few
hours after an earthquake or another
natural disaster we save as many lives
as possible I raised this in the House
of Commons with Prime Minister Gordon
Brown I think there's more we can do
both in the UK and internationally and I
think that should be a real priority as
we start to learn the lessons of how we
could do even better when the next hated
strikes